ah no never dude I have a terrible
[ __ ] story actually this is when he
told us the story we couldn't stop
talking about it for weeks
oh yeah as the talk of the dinner table
talk of the dinner this story about Pat
had sex with another woman again check
it out check this one out this one's
different than the rest god
so awesome your water yeah this was no
water from a very disgusting person that
we will not speak about on this podcast
she who we will not name yeah
Valda [ __ ] Valda don't say her name
more than once oh I gotta do so much in
packaging extortion so I was dating this
Australian girl wasn't Wade Willis Wade
Whammer whoever the [ __ ] so I was dating
this Australian girl we were dating it
was cool she was beautiful it was
[ __ ] it was nice and she was at my
house we're hooking up and she was on
her period and I'm not really in a
period sex because like there's blood
and I'm not lucky I don't I'm just like
I'll wait I'll wait you know I don't
mind waiting
so we're hooking up things are getting
heated and she's like okay like work I'm
like okay well how about you know I put
it in your butt like I'm so cute that's
somebody's nervous is like the first
tell ty is a sign for somebody's [ __ ]
nervous is where their voice is hired
out there like that
all innocent and she was like yeah she
was down okay we're all bashful
now before before this I've tried like a
couple times like I and I've it's never
really been successful like I've done a
few pumps and I'm like
it starts smelling like doodoo and I'm
like you know I'm I don't know every
time I do it I'm like why did I do this
again I don't I know I don't like it
well I will tell you this so I found out
on JK news there's a dudes gig I guess
he's like a gay gay expert or something
[ __ ] like that like any kind of gay
topic that's what he was no front
YouTube he would talk about butt sex and
[ __ ] and then we literally had a whole
episode on JK news where he was
informing us I don't know how to have
anal sex which episode is this one you
are number wise it was like you don't
just go in and you start [ __ ]
somebody yeah he does you there's a
whole process you have to really clean
diet [ __ ] everything out enema clean
that [ __ ] out and then you start [ __ ]
in the ass like if you just start doing
a tan or she's gonna smell like [ __ ]
that sounds like a lot of work the horn
doesn't teach you that they don't tell
you that when you stick in the me ask
it's clean and she sticks it in her
mouth yeah yeah see I didn't I didn't
know any of that I just went in there
like okay let's just like a [ __ ]
idiot like oh let's just see what
happens here like let's try let's I'm
feeling adventurous so man and it's
daytime too it's like 3 p.m. I think
that's an important detail the Sun was
still up it was a hot day there was a
raven in their rowing there was woodoo
in the air so Dookie babies down dodo so
we're doing what [ __ ] we're doing a
thing right so I put it in and like the
usual like I go slow you know I mean the
I got in there got in there and we
started having sex and then was like
kind of it was going well it was like oh
wow like this ni like felt like oh wow
like I'm doing something new it's like
like some little rush dude yeah I got
like a housewife that did like a new
thing or something I was like wow like I
can really be this person this is a new
chapter in my life and so we're going at
it and like I'm about to come and I'm
like hey like I tell her I'm if I I'm
like I'm about to finish
I'm about to come and she says don't
come in my ass which I was confused
because like well that's not gonna get
pregnant like yeah exactly
it seems like the ideal place to come
but okay you already letting me do this
is pretty nice I sent I will I'll honor
your request like yeah so a couple pumps
and I pull out and you always have to
grab and like you you got to give a
couple more strokes so I'm like I'm
reaching for my dick and I look and my
dick is just covered in [ __ ] like green
doodoo that's an important detail Green
3 p.m. 3 PS Akaka the Dookie was great
the middle of July so I go to I go to
grab and do the couple pumps but I see
and I'm like I'm horrified and I start
like dry heaving because I smell it and
like so now I'm but I'm still coming so
I'm coming and almost throwing up at the
same time you came
like I'm like interesting that like
zapping between dimensions dude you look
good and my dick is just kind of like
it's just all about upset at you and I
just yeah I just didn't I didn't I just
opened the windows wreaked in there that
is they grabbed a towel flying they and
said nothing I said nothing she said
nothing and I just went upstairs
showered and then you guys broke up
yeah shortly after that she could never
look you the eye again you don't even
look at me all you do is smell me all
you do is when I walk in the room you
just pinch your nose like calling me PU
[ __ ] green crayons all day with the
hug your [ __ ] you have to go eat
dinner and you're sitting there and
you're like maybe you should ease up on
the spinach nice to bring everything
green away from her why would you let me
have some salad
oops why are you always pooping what do
you have oh so much [ __ ] your butt all
the time that's already had its force
green yeah like I'm added about dude
that's an amazing yeah that was the last
I think that's the last time I'll ever
unless I meet a girl that's a
professional that's like hey I don't
think in the whole clean intuition and
I'll think about it but other than that
like I'm pretty happy with vagina yeah I
don't like it at all and the reason why
is number one poops in there yeah right
that's where poop is from and it's
supposed to go out this way outgoing I
only also the one time that I did try it